[Applaudissements]
deuxième entre les deux je pense que
c'est le téléfilm de france 3 qui va
être premier toit deuxième je t'avais
langue avec moi ouais konami nous en
spectacle avec moi ou ça y est j'ai pas
il ya je pense leur avoir huit
spectacles je t'amène avec moi je te tu
viens tu souffres est monté sur scène à
un moment et on passe toute la soirée et
la nuit je t'emmène avec moi aussi non
j'espère aller de pro b les odeurs alors
ma femme est d'accord ton mari faut lui
demander il est toujours d'avoir la
preuve on vraiment la preuve je
proposais j'en ai parlé aux gens ça
serait quand même qui nous film a bien
sûr dans le lit à poil mais on aura la
nature du film borat on a l'habitude des
hommes bien qu'ils chaude
quand vous arrêtez pas de brancher ma
copine en lui disant que les vieilles je
suis pas qu avec toi les paviens moi je
suis sûr que couché à côté à côté de moi
nue je pense que je peux avoir un
résultat visible
écoutez non j'ai non mais alors ça vous
paierez n'impose qui viennent dire oui
voilà qui sort du soir patrick en direct
sur france 2 c'est sa machine sio